Corea del Norte vigilará Estados Unidos
y sus aliados desde el
espaciong las autoridades anunciaron en
el lanzamiento de un satélite militar
espía para finales de mayo o principios
de junio el satélite de reconocimiento
militar número 1 será lanzado en junio
para hacer frente a las peligrosas
acciones militares de Estados Unidos y
sus vasallos según analistas el
lanzamiento de este satélite se hace en
el marco de la voluntad de
desarrollar un programa tecnológico de
vigilancia destinado a mejorar la
precisión de sus misiles en caso de
guerra
los satélites de reconocimiento son
esenciales para aumentar la precisión de
los ataques preventivos y para el avance
de las fuerzas nucleares además también
representan las contramedidas de Corea
del Norte contra los satélites de
reconocimiento surcoreanos y
estadounidenses y el Primer Ministro
japonés fumida protestó ante las
intenciones de su vecino
aunque se describía como un satélite un
lanzamiento con tecnología de misil
balístico sería una violación de las
resoluciones de seguridad de la ONU y un
grave problema que amenazaría la
seguridad pública
el gobierno japonés ha decidido poner en
alerta a sus sistemas de defensa por su
parte Corea del Sur ha estado
actualmente a abandonar su proyecto
según la ha anunciado su intención de
cooperar estrechamente con Washington y
Tokio para responder a lo que considera
provocaciones de su vecino del Norte